حصلت الجزيره على نسخه من اخر مسوده
لمشروع قرار يناقشه مجلس الامن الدولي
بشان توسيع نطاق المساعدات الانسانيه الى
غزه ومراقبتها وتكتفي المسوده بالمطالبه
باتخاذ خطوات عاجله للسماح للسماح بوصول
فوري للمساعدات وتهيئه الظروف لوقف مستدام
للاعمال العدائيه وكانت الصيغه السابقه
تدعو الى تعليق عاجل للاعمال القتاليه
واتخاذ خطوات عاجله نحو وقف مستدام
للاعمال القتاليه كما تم تعديل ثلاثه بنود
كانت تتعلق بانشاء اليه لتسريع ومراقبه
ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه تحت سلطه
الامين العام للمنظمه حيث نصت المسوده
الجديده على تعيين منسق للشؤون الانسانيه
واعاده الاعمار لتولي انشاء اليه امميه
لتسريع المساعدات وتبسيط عملي ايصالها
وضمان وصولها الى وجهاتها ويطلب المشروع
تشكيل اليه باسرع وقت ممكن تحت سلطه الامم
المتحده وحذفت من من مسو المشروع القرار
ماده تدين الهجمات العشوائيه على المدنيين
والاعيان المدنيه وجميع اعمال
العنف معنا من مقر الامم المتحده في
نيويورك مراسل الجزيره مراد هاشم مراد
باذا عن هذه المسوده التي اطلعت عليها
والمؤشرات في هذه الجلسه
مرحبا عبد القادر نعم الجلسه جلسه
المشاورات المغلقه والتي تعقد وهي الثانيه
التي تعقد اليوم لا تزال مستمره في ضوء
نتائج هذه المشاورات الجاريه حاليا سوف
يتحدد ما اذا كان سيكون هناك تصويت على
هذه المسوده الاخيره ام سيتم تاجيل جديد
اخر علما ان تاجيلات
تحدث منذ الاثنين الماضي
وا اساسا
بسبب تعديلات تطالب الولايات المتحده بها
لان الصيغه في الواقع ما قبل الاخيره كانت
تحظى باجماع اغلبيه اعضاء مجلس الامن
الدولي وكانت هناك على الاقل تتوفر تسعه
اصوات لمرور هذه المسوده اذا لم يكن هناك
فيتو ولكن هذه المشاورات المتواصله تهدف
الى تجنب هذا الفيتو هذه الصيغه المسوده
الاخيره المعدله علمنا من مصادر دبلوماسيه
ان
الفلسطينيين غير راضين عنها وكذلك روسيا
وعدد من الاعضاء اضافه الى اسرائيل ال
النقاشات كما نسمع ونتابع حاده وساخنه
داخل المجلس ولا يعلم مال هذه الجلسه جلسه
المشاورات
الحاليه بطبيعه الحال نص اضعف في المسوده
الاخيره كثيرا بالاشاره فقط الى ما يتعلق
الى ما كان يفترض دعوه لوقف الاعمال
القتاليه وكانت عدلت بعد ذلك بطلب من
الولايات المتحده الى تعليق
ا عاجل للاعمال القتاليه واتخذ واتخاذ
خطوات فوريه لوقف مستدام للاعمال القتاليه
هذه الماده ايضا اضعفت اكثر الان في
المسوده في المسوده الاخيره وتدعو الى
اتخاذ خطوات لتسريع صال المساعدات
الانسانيه اي مجرد خطوات دون الدعوه الى
اي شكل من اشكال الهدن او ايقاف وقف وقف
اطلاق النار ا ما يثير التساؤل كيف يمكن
تسريع وايصال المساعدات الانسانيه فيما
الاعمال القتاليه مستمره الكثيرون يثيرون
هذا السؤال رغم ان المسوده الاخيره تشير
في الواقع الى ما يتعلق بت تهيئه الظروف
لوقف مستدام للاعمال القتاليه اي ان الامر
هو دعوه لتهيئه الظروف ليس هناك دعوه في
المسوده الاخيره لاي اشكال من اشكال
الهدنه او وقف اطلاق النار عبد القادر وهي
صيغه تضع هذا المشروع اضعف بكثير من
القرار الذي اعتمده المجلس ذاته في ال عش
من نوفمبر الماضي ومر باغلبيه الاصوات مع
تحفض الولايات المتحده في ذلك الوقت
التعديل الاهم ايضا كان يتعلق بنقطه خلا
رئيسيه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
المسوده ما قبل
الاخيره التي وزعت باللون الازرق كانت
تشير الى تطلب من الامين العام للامم
المتحده انشاء اليه لتسريع ورصد ومراقبه
المساعدات الانسانيه التي تدخل الى قطاع
غزه عبر البر والبحر والجو وهي انشاء
وانشاء اليه في قطاع غزه تحت سلطته وبمو
ظفين ومعدات من الامم المتحده على ان ينسق
مع السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل في هذا
الشان وان ويطالب بتسريع انشاء هذه الاليه
وال بطبيعه الحال ايضا التعاون معها هذه
الاليه الان عدلت بشكل كبير اللغه التي
تستخدمها المسوده الاخيره اضعف بكثير واقل
الزاميه ولا تشير
الى اشارات مثلا من قبيل ان هذه الاليه
تعمل داخل قطاع غزه ومن اجل ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه بشكل سريع عبر كافه
المعابر وهو الهدف الاساسي من هذا المشروع
في الاساس هو ان يتم تسهيل ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه عبر كل الطرق
والوسائل برا وبحرا وجوا باشراف من الامم
المتحده وسلطتها فيما التعديل الاخير في
الواقع يؤجل الامور الى حين تعيين منسق
للشؤون الانسانيه وشؤون اعاده الاعمار على
ان يتولى هو بعد ذلك اقتراح انشاء اليه
للتسريع بايصال المساعدات وضمان وصولها
الى وجهاتها وهو يدعو الى التعاون مع
المنسق وانشا هذه الاليه بشكل سريع ب
الاستعانه بموظفين ومعدات الامم المتحده
وتحت سلطتها لكن تبقى هذه التعديلات بشان
اليه ايضا اضعفت كثيرا من الواضح ان هذه
نقطه اخذت الكثير من المشاورات وفي الواقع
مع ذلك لا يعلم ما اذا كانت الولايات
المتحده لا تزال عليها اعتراضات على هذه
الصيغه المعدله اذ ان الولايات المتحده لم
تكن تريد في الاساس وجود هذه الاليه وفي
الواقع ان هذه الاليه وضعت او اقترحت في
المشروع كي لا تبقى المساعده الانسانيه هي
ورقه ضغط تستخدمها اسرائيل كما هو في
الواقع في اي صفقات واتفاقات بشان الافراج
عن الاسرى وكي لا يبقى قطاع غزه تحت
الحصار كليا من قبل اسرائيل المنظمات
الانسانيه تشير الى ان اسرائيل تستخدم
التجويع سلاحا ضد السكان وكان الهدف من
هذا المشروع وهذه الاليه هو الا يكون ذلك
كليا بيد اسرائيل الحصار والمساعدات
الانسانيه
والغذاء بطبي ط الحال مع ذلك سنرى الى اين
ستؤول هذه المناقشات وما اذا كان سيكون
هناك تصويتا عن سؤالك الان نشاهد الان في
الصور القاعه في داخل المجلس تبدو فارغه
هل هي مجرد استراحه ام مؤشر على انه ايضا
يجري سيجري ايضا تاجيل هذه
الجلسه نعم بالفعل عبد القادر هذه الصوره
نتابعها منذ انطلاق المشاورات
المغلقه رسميا في جد جدول مجلس الامن
الدولي هناك جلسه مشاورات مغلقه تعقبها
جلسه مفتوحه بشان الشرق الاوسط والقضيه
الفلسطينيه اي ان هناك يفترض ان يكون هناك
تصويت بل وكذلك تصريحات للسفير الامريكيه
بعد ذلك ولكن ما نعلمه ان جلسه التصويت
اساسا مبنيه على ما سيتم في هذه المشاورات
وهناك كما علمنا الكثير في الواقع من
الخلافات والتباينات وعدم الرضا حول هذه
المسوده روسيا تحديدا في الواقع غير سعيده
بهذه التعديلات بل كان المشروع قبل
المسوده الاخيره لم يكن كليا مرضيا
بالنسبه للروس ولكنهم كانوا مع ذلك يدفعون
من اجل تصويت عاجل على مسوده باللون
الازرق اي قبل التعديل الاخير لان الوضع
الانساني في غزه لا يحتمل التاخير ولان
بالنسبه لروسيا الولايات المتحده فقط
تمارس لعبه اللعب على الوقت ل اتاحه مزيد
من المجال والوقت لاسرائيل مع عدم ابداء
اي نيه حقيقيه فيما يتعلق بما اذا كانت
ستسمح بتمرير المشروع من عدمه اي لكن ذلك
بالطبيعه الحال سيتبين سريعا اليوم وربما
غدا عبد القادر